we might be drunk
we
might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] pet peeves wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
welcome to the comedians inspired by uh
jerry seinfeld and dave attell i am the
co-host wait which one is jim gaffigan
i don't know comedy anyway
the more robotic is more like uh is more
like seinfeld
and then the the self-loathing that is
uh you know it's gonna be really
interesting to see what you guys look
like when you grow up
because it's gonna there's gonna be
you're at this point
jim should i let you guys talk we're up
38 so it's not like you don't look a day
over 37. i'll take it no but like there
is going to be a point where
in your comedy generation take it i'm
74.
and there's going to be a point where
you know
you know what i mean maybe it's not
youtube but like maybe it's
someone where you're like that guy or
that gal was completely normal and now
they're bonkers oh yeah
right a lot of that now covered covered
revealed a lot of that as you said and
you're special right yeah yeah it's a
lot of crazy out there yeah yeah then
it's getting wackier i think the social
media that's staying at home and just
reading horrible [ __ ] all day it changes
a person yeah
it's crazy anyway that's the episode
[Music]
all right well we should introduce
one of my favorite comics uh thank you
for coming coming straight from the view
jim gaffney
well i went to the view then i got my
booster wow which i mean obviously it's
all you know uh fake anyway but no i got
my booster so
they they're like can you hang here for
15 minutes and i'm like yeah and so then
i just left because you know why
because i don't pay attention to rules
hell yeah you're really faded in the cab
and i was raped which was really bad
so i gotta go uber
so what are you guys drinking and
what are you trying to make up for um
so much uh drinking lagavulin pd nice
scotch it's a it's a special scotch the
seinfeld is a special car for a special
guest we do the same thing with alcohol
oh you do a different a different drink
oh we've got mai tai eggnog bourbon you
name it everybody so
how do you decide like do you guys know
about booze you know about different
boozes we know a little and how much
there's a little bit of an old soul in
both of you guys mm-hmm
you do i think yeah
even when
i am old no
i mean i remember your first half hour
on comedy center and i was like this is
a joke guys huge yeah now i heard
something weird about you and tell me if
i'm wrong um you wanted to be love it
you wanted to be a tellish and then you
end up being reganish and then geraldo
wanted to be real she wanted to tell us
you and you know like how you guys are
lovers geraldo and i were lovers ah and
uh no the you have these comedy kind of
and i know that there's other people in
your group so i don't want to alienate
them but
but uh geraldo really wanted to be like
regan
and i really wanted to be like a tell
and uh there was kind of this shift that
occurred
and uh you know he ended up doing the
roasts and
um and you know some of it is like it's
you find different levels of
authenticity right
and it depends how it changes and how
your heart's broken yeah i mean i think
bill burr was clean as a whistle in the
beginning was he billy burr yeah he was
well i know him as billy burr which is
really interesting like there was
something of like
i don't know if you've known anyone
that's kind of like had a gender change
like where you're like now they're they
yeah
and so like like build billy bill was a
little bit of that oh really it was like
i had to catch myself out of respect you
know what i mean
right now he's this massive powerhouse
huge yeah he totally found himself yeah
but now he's going through all this
therapy and he's taking shrooms it's
everybody's finding themselves and
changing
seems to be in therapy right now oh yeah
but haven't they all you know what's
weird is like you guys
are drinking i feel as though this is
therapy there were there was less
drinkers i mean there was always like a
towel you always hear about the coke and
the hotels and the hooks yeah i mean but
i'm talking about like i'm not talking
about like way back i'm talking about
you know because in my
generation or whatever uh
you know like
like geraldo and i would get wasted but
like
and a tell would drink
but like
louie didn't drink todd berry you know
like i'm not saying they didn't drink at
all kevin brennan
mark maron and it was or it just wasn't
in the open like the weird thing is is
like
uh in this what we do
you're like you're performing in a bar
yeah essentially whether it's a club or
not and you're like this is a sweet
setup for after the show i don't know if
it's still like that in clubs where
you're like show's over
you got free booths here
let's hang out right yeah i think that's
why i became a comic i was like 18. i
was like free bo free bar yeah was id me
we got paid and drink tickets yeah it
was just pushing the addiction but now
every comics like yogaing therapy and
kaling you know it's all about like neil
brennan goes on these retreats where he
finds him his dad or whatever it's crazy
stuff wow
yeah that's that's pretty interesting
well it's this journey right we're
always
it's like but for comedians we're just
looking for material do i mean it's like
uh maybe i should maybe that inner child
has some jokes i could use yeah do you
know what i mean that's why i'm having
kids you're like i mean we're obviously
inspired by you say like sci-fi natal
but we're inspired by guys like youtube
because you're so observational like
you'll you'll put i just watch your new
special it's hilarious
but i'm like how many minutes did he
have on bikers that was untouched like
how the [ __ ] did he hit that i know
you're going to run out of stuff you
milk the [ __ ] out of everything oh well
thank you i you know it's like but
as you guys know you feel like
you're like well that might be it and
then there is
you know uh necessity is the mother of
invention right right is that even the
quote that i i think
sounds good i kind of said it smart
who's the smartest here is it or one of
you is like a closet smart person not me
not you maybe wait a minute you grew up
in new york city you're a reader you're
well-read
but i but i say we always defer to the
jewish person he is jewish he's smart
it's like it's like the gay person being
creative all right we're just gonna have
to say
yeah the black guy's athletic the jews
are uh you got an accounting degree
i assume no oh that was and that was
like that you sounded more anti-semitic
yeah
he said he hated bagel choices you're
not jewish i wish i think that like all
comedians because it has such a rich
history and borch belt i think all
gentile comedians
secretly want to be jewish i think so
too yeah and you know us honkies you at
least have a little flavor a little
culture you know you're on a farm i'm
just thinking about this in my eyebrows
i don't just look like i'm on a farm but
your your family owns slaves that's true
still yeah still owen slater i know so
your family you're from new orleans oh
yeah born and raised you your family
manufactured confederate statues which i
think is really weird yeah yeah you guys
suppressed
poor white people too big time yeah and
is your family from new orleans or you
guys carpet bag or
they're scallywags uh and turncoats no
they're from there they're from their
wedding and katrina came and they won't
leave they just won't go away so they're
and are you cajun are you like theo
vaughn are you related to theo are you
theovon's dad he's my brother no dad was
80.
that's true
yeah maybe we had material about that
yeah but new orleans is not that weird i
mean if you go it's like a little city
but then you go ten minutes outside of
it and you're in the hoot nanny it's
crazy right it's toothless it's camo
it's it's but that's new york too
you're 20 minutes outside the city and
you're like what the hell but you grew
sam you grew up in the city in the city
yeah the rough and tumble city did you
go to bronx science or something no
we've talked about it's browning really
yeah oh yeah browning that's right see
come on that's smart that's smart rough
and tumble you grew up in chelsea
and then and then upper east yeah
it's like i think it's amazing how like
you have conversations have you ever had
this with comedians where you're like
you're like yeah we drove to pittsburgh
do you remember that and you're like
yeah
kind of like you should remember an
eight hour eight hour all right and you
had a great conversation you did a show
you had a meal you got drunk drove back
and you don't remember any of it all
right what's your favorite city to
perform in
i mean i love it it also depends on the
club yeah i mean i love i was gonna say
comedy on state because of that yeah
that club and you love the the owner's
daughters
you're very inappropriate you wanted to
get all chris knowth on them
a friend of mine i don't know what to
say ah
peloton yeah that's tough
what uh so that's a great club yeah i
performed there that's a great club
that's a classic i mean great little
town too madison's underrated city is
big chicago is just always on yeah
acme in minneapolis is good yeah that's
the dc improv the dc improv was my
favorite i've never done a weekend there
have you ever really yeah great room low
ceiling tight i love a club in the heart
of the city like philly helium right
there in the city i hate when you got i
just did in the milwaukee improv shout
out great club milwaukee and has an
improv just open oh in august and it's a
good club staff was great in the third
ward or where is it oh you wish it is in
the 15th ward it is out by uh you know i
was in kenosha i was open for
rittenhouse
it's wild
but it's way out there what you did
those clubs are like you've been a road
guy for like how many years yeah you're
40 50 years me and joey diaz were out
there
[Laughter]
um
no i did a lot of uh road stuff actually
initially
when uh people were doing
road gigs around i only stayed in the
city
but i didn't really get set so it was
kind of uh i would do gladys comedy club
whoa i would do that that was at
hamburger harry's where's that
that was on 45th street wow
damn and then um
where else did i perform gotham was the
place that really let me go on the 21st
street gotham yes that was a cool room
that was a cool road that felt like
comedy in there but i didn't really
start touring until uh like i middled
for a tell
like when he would do the dc improv and
i met like the dc improv and i'm sure
it's still the great club
was a great club it was like the wait
staff was cool
and um
it was just you know like i feel like dc
is one of those cities where people are
over educated right and underpaid yeah
they're like we can't do anything but go
to a comedy show right i mean totally
yeah yeah great town uh
opening for a tell yeah he was drinking
i assume
he was but you know like the weird thing
is i used to
i used to you know like the attel
this is kind of goes back to what i said
it's like
there's these
these aspects of these comedians that is
it more mystique than anything do you
want to hear my larger theory is that
comedians
are all an identity crisis every single
one of us
so in other words
some of it is who we're we're told who
we are yes by the audience and by other
comedians it's just how we come across
like i come across as very handsome no i
come across as very white bread right
very midwestern
but the reality is i you know i grew up
middle class uh you know i went to
college
but that's not to say that
i'm not
you know like the the white trash stuff
it it isn't far from me you know i mean
it's like it is part of who i am you
know i did collect beer cans as a kid
right so
but the thing about a tell is that
the the attel i knew and not that you
ever really know comedians except for
you guys have made love
that you never really know comedians
that well
but
a tell was this workhorse oh yeah he was
you know he might have a beer to unwind
but he was not like
shit-faced every night and he's a cute
jewish government long island yeah that
was this gruff kind of blue collar yeah
but he was yeah so he was like this
brilliant jewish kid from great neck or
whatever
it's like and
but like the uh the kind of like uh
the bowery boy thing
was i felt like it was and i used to
give him [ __ ] i'm like you're like this
smart kid from long island and he's like
yeah you're just being nice right but
like
but he became that in a way
do i mean and that's also you know i
didn't you know obviously he did
struggle with drinking and obviously he
smokes too much and stuff like that
um
but so i'm simplifying it and i don't
know all the details but it was well you
got to have a thing when we were in dc
yeah like
he would he would go out for a drink but
he was
like the attell i knew was like he'd go
and even when he was writing things on
come at comedy central
he he would i would be like i'll help
you out you know just i'll just hang
around
and
he was he was very kind of
uh he would never
stay in a place like he'd go to a car
he'd be like you want a beer and i'm
like uh sure and then he'd be like i'm
gonna go and you didn't know it wasn't
like he was being rude he's like a
bodega cat you kind of yeah he's kind of
here and then he's gone you know yes but
like the one of the i mean i think one
of the best comedic minds but also a
really sweet guy yeah you know totally
we love him he was not like
uh you know like i mean i don't think
i've ever seen him walk by a homeless
person and not yeah yeah money and there
are a lot of them in the west village
he is the only person still carrying
cash in the west village yeah he pulls
out a wad i've also never seen him eat
have you seen him once because i used to
do the road with him a decent amount i
remember he we pulled over driving back
and i saw him take like a sausage
biscuit out of a gas station i took a
big bite and i was like man i've never
seen them eat that's so funny have you
yeah we went to keene's with him that
time we you've seen the media at a
burger you've seen me i don't know it's
rarely i think he put it in his pocket
and left
but you you you know you guys know and i
don't know if you guys
but like i tell there was a time
when he would have i'm not kidding a new
20 minutes oh every night it's unreal
every night and he would just
like i remember the second time so there
was
back when letterman was a big to-do
and obviously so like there's
the
and i i call them classes but
generations like the class right above
me and geraldo and
trying to think of who else would be in
there ian bagg um
bonnie mcfarlane uh
they were just
like they would decimate and there were
these people that were but they were the
new comics getting all the spots or
getting the
the spots when someone would go out of
town
but like the reason i bring that up let
me see if i can remember
is that but he would have the this new
material every night so when he did
letterman he did it was a big thing like
i think that todd berry was the first
one to do letter really it ended up just
working out that way
so all these guys were great barry
uh marin you know kevin brennan they
were all like of that same and louis
and so but like a tell was the one that
they there was a new york times article
that identified him as the new mel
brooks whoa
he was on he was on this 30 under 30 30
uh artist list in the new york times and
there wasn't
this uh
[Music]
you know like the the
journalism
that that is focused on comedy
obviously we know it's a bigger deal in
the uk
the journalism on comedy thing but like
there was no journalism on comedy
so they would the new yorker the new
york times
and the new yorker
every two years would send someone out
to follow a couple comedians
and they would
you know it would depend who they
followed so sometimes they would follow
a tell or sarah silverman and sometimes
they would follow someone who really
wasn't in the scene ah
so like you know like when you read a a
review or an article
about a comedian you're like this person
doesn't know comedy yes they're not even
they're they're not even scraping the
surface of what an audience responds to
to this
comedian
they'll follow someone who's like an it
kid or something but they're not they're
not doing the work
or they'll even kind of
or an actor they're kind of yeah they're
just like oh this is just somebody who
uh pedals and tabloid stuff
yeah but uh you could argue there's too
much comedy journalism like hey relax we
got it
right yeah it is it's in have you guys
performed in the uk because the uk it's
it's um
it's kind of part of the fabric reviews
and um they say that edinboro the
reviews are what get you seats yeah it's
very it's
it's weird it's almost like the uk and
obviously this changes all the time you
know and i'm sure even in your time
doing stand-up it's changed you're like
wow can you believe this
club that used to be up here is now down
here stand up new york it's no or like
next trip or just you know the comic
strip is where i started so it is weird
like to see it kind of do this you know
i mean and it just it
it moves also with uh
you know the management of the club and
also like
how that club is run like if it's not a
true
uh
showcase you know if there's also just
geography of where people live
yeah you know uh it can change but you
would have that with hbo remember hbo
was the top tier
you couldn't get any higher than hbo
special yeah and i'm not saying hbo is
nothing but it doesn't feel like the
most eyeballs are there
yeah comedy and by the way i remember
like
you know hbo was definitely the most
prestigious thing but
i remember i mean i was very fortunate
because beyond the pale that was comedy
central right that was comedy central
and that was
during this period where
um
dorm rooms so like when i went to
college
there was maybe something in the the
common area that had cable
but mtv was on yeah but but during the
time beyond the pail premiered that's
when everyone had a tv in their room
everyone had comedy central on 24 hours
a day
and so like people were kind of
you know forced to be exposed right
right whereas now i mean i don't you
know it's like look as a comedian you
want to be on comedy central you want to
you know
but it's it doesn't have the weight that
it did god i mean like there's look all
these swords and all the
the weight of
a youtube special you know you two guys
did the youtube specials that like
there is that independence there oh yeah
and so you have to navigate your own
path and in some ways
it's shifting so like even if someone
asked you like hey that youtube special
how'd you do that what what'd you do
it's like
even in the year
it's probably shifted where you might be
like you know what now i would do this
or that or you're gonna get some money
here or you're gonna have to
uh you know and you've got your netflix
special so it's like it's this shifting
thing but that's kind of
i mean i'm glad to be back with netflix
i'm dying to see how the numbers do
because you don't know you don't know
it's a gamble i only got the netflix
because of the youtube success so then
you're like well maybe i should just
stay with youtube so it's this weird
juggling act of you're like i don't know
what's more
beneficial for my career it's i mean
it's a lot of people i really respect i
remember when i did the youtube special
i talked to people who you know i really
respect who are like you're an idiot if
you do this like you're done
who are like you can't ever give it away
for free yeah so so that was but then
also it's like what is a special but
kind of a trailer for
yourself on the road
so yeah i was kind of well i'm done with
the material no one really made an offer
this is kind of what you do i think i'm
not doing this i'm doing this because i
want to write new jokes you know so
yeah i think i think youtube has has
been it's the number one competitor to
netflix which is incredible it's like
it's not amazon it's not hbo so it's
comedy at least it's so interesting
because i i had done a couple comedy
central specials
and you know you're also
you know you want to
um
like people think oh it's money it's
never money it's about eyeballs yes
and the thing is is that
you know the thing about um
you know like being new also
is you only get to be new for a little
bit you got that right like by the way
that's a scary reality
where
oh yeah that's right they only want to
write articles about
discovery they don't want i mean unless
you
you know really kind of i mean i've
never been a tabloid guy anyway unless
you do something outlandish or you're
you know that'd be great for your next
run you just start doing russell crowe
level tabloid [ __ ] no just like i'm just
attacking something
group and i'm like you can't deal with
it
but jim gaffigan's edgy trans chunk
yeah but it's like it's weird how it's
always shifting and that's the business
side of it yeah and that's not
necessarily
again it's not about finance it's about
creating
opportunities so that you can continue
to do it exactly like you guys did the i
don't even you don't even need to tell
me you did the youtube thing
so that
you could get asses and seats at clubs
so that those people could be like you
know what i saw this they can easily
share it there is no paywall i mean by
the way when i did
amazon and that's why i'm so excited to
go back to netflix because
when my last netflix
netflix
special was
when they were releasing one
every week yeah and sometimes twice a
week it's a lot
and it would appear and it would
disappear
and so
you could get some bump but like also
uh you wouldn't get the imp like you
know like i remember like i'm i i love
nate bargassi but i was like that
bastard it's like his special came out
in the middle of the pandemic oh yeah
there was not much stuff out there so
there's a lot of value yeah in when
things land like aziz it's like even
aziz is special it was
brilliant because he was the first one
that they owned so they had an interest
in
promoting it so it was like
you know so there's
so many other things there's some people
think it's like one thing or another
it's luck is such a big part of it it's
not just yeah it's not a good size the
strangeness of timing yeah it's like our
business is all about timing but then
there's a lot of timing you don't have
control over yes but sometimes it's
bittersweet because some people put a
youtube out too quick it's like you said
you can only be young and new once so
some people are like oh i can put out a
youtube special or an album and they
just do it and you're like you could
have waited five years you'd be better
off but it's too enticing exactly the
demand for content has has hurt quality
for sure sure yeah yeah it is weird
because
there is something i mean i i've changed
and this is like such classic comedy
nerd talk that like we would talk about
if we were just hanging out i love it is
that and you know by the way seinfeld is
like thinks i'm crazy is that
you know how long does it take to bake
an hour right oh yeah and he's like you
know the the english or the british or
the irish and the australians
they do an hour a year yeah now i think
that's inherently wrong agreed
but they all stink
i don't know what they all think but i
don't know you know it's like by the way
it's a bit much look whether you liked
it or not and i don't want to get down
the rabbit hole of hannah gatsby that
special that popped
nanette
was her ninth is that right
and i'm like
so she did nine and by the way whether
you you know wow i didn't know whether
you think it's uh artistic piece or
super funny super importance from a
socio standpoint
that was a pretty complete piece
for her
let's say eighth or ninth
and so like there is something of like
are we putting and i'm saying this to
two guys that can write
like to the people that can't write i'm
like
that's that you know that that's got to
be frustrating
but like
you know
we're also workhorses right yeah we are
kind of the tell kind of like grind it
out the joke is the hero the the
facilitator is not as important as the
material
you know i mean and so i just don't get
how other people do it they go hey
you're one of those joke guys i'm like
what else is are we doing here i'm a
comedian like it has to be jokes and
you're telling the director you're in
the scenes yeah right right
i don't get it like what else would you
say
you sing songs
so you just sit well the thing is is i
think that
i sometimes wonder about that too is
that you can do stories but they have to
have jokes you have to have jokes yeah
and some of it is
it's all
self-assignment and and we are always
trying to evolve
you know like when i look at like um
like some of these fitness inspirational
guys it's like i wish there were people
like that just talking about comedy like
you gotta come up with another [ __ ]
hour you gotta do it you gotta challenge
yourself you gotta wake up you gotta go
i'm gonna i'm gonna freak myself out i'm
gonna say something embarrassing you
gotta go up there you gotta embarrass
yourself because that's the only way
you're gonna grow you're gonna sit there
and do food jokes for ten years do that
then you'll be a fat [ __ ] ass yeah
you gotta get out there and you gotta
prove yourself i dare you to do an act
out do an echo tonight yeah no i don't
wanna do it we might be drunk is brought
to you by sheath underwear whether
you're worried about having your dick
stuck to your balls or your balls stuck
to your dick or your leg stuck to your
dick it's time to get sheathed let me
see are you wearing you're not wearing
it man
is this not sheath
whoops
let's take it again this is sheath
[ __ ] there it is get some
sorry robert
sheath is great i i really like this
underwear oh i wear it consciously and
i'll tell you my girlfriend is like i
love that underwear and i'm like guess
what it's [ __ ] sheath so get some
hell yeah uh keeps your balls off your
leg two patches one for your dick one
for your balls nothing sticks the
patterns are solid
stretchy fabric yeah you don't feel
confined there's nothing worse than like
underwear where there's no uh
out for your dick
over the hump and you're like what am i
pissing over a [ __ ] brick
that's so true sheath isn't just for men
there's lady drunks out there too we got
they got sports bras bikini briefs and
and uh boy shorts i gotta be honest i
don't know about this stuff for women
because i'm a guy i bet it's great
because the guy's stuff is killer oh
yeah uh
loving it mark tell him what to do
by the way my lady loves the the bras so
go to sheath underwear dot com and use
code drunk to get 20 off your first
order plus she's underwear 100
100 money back guarantee that sheath
underwear dot com promo code drunk get
sheath underwear and let them support
your balls baby
love your sheath
get on it support the show get 20 off
free shipping with the code drunk at
sheath underwear dot com thank you
we might be drunk as sponsored by better
help online therapy we've talked about
better help on this show before and this
month we're discussing some of the
stigmas around mental health first off
you're not a crazy person it doesn't
mean something's wrong with you taking
talking to a therapist is a positive way
to process your life
look we do therapy you got me in it's
necessary it's helpful people go to the
gym people eat right what about your
mind what about your emotions what about
your mental state we all have trauma
we're all [ __ ] up we're all weirdos
gotta get on it
just like going to the gym or the
dentist we should be caring for our
mental health as much as our physical
health
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even online
or live chat sessions with your
therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can start communicating
with your therapist in under 48 hours
give it a try see why over 2 million
people have used betterhelp online
therapy this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp and you get 10 off your first
month by going to betterhelp.com
drunk
that's b e t t e r h e l p dot com slash
drunk and check out better help's new
podcast getting better
wow stories of mental health here megan
traynor open up about motherhood or how
nba hall of famer chris bosh tames
anxiety one of my favorites love chris
bosh there you go find getting better on
apple spotify and anywhere else you get
your podcast support the show
and get 10 off your first month of
online therapy betterhelp.com drunk get
on it i always see your act like i'd see
you even back in the day you'd work like
small rooms and i
and i'm really not blowing you here but
like you would
i would never see it weak really like i
was curious it's a good point where do
you work out
where's your where's like your open mic
because i i would see you at bars i'd be
like this new stuff is already polished
well that's very nice but yeah there's
um that's all the wife
not much stuff
it's no it's it's um
some of it it's like i've been doing it
for 70 years
but some of it is
you but you can never know 100 what's
going to kill you yeah you never know
but like that's also
you know it's the risk and the reward
right
it's like it's like that that crypto ad
you know it's like
it's that people are so angry about it
but like i do think there is
i don't know i mean because sometimes
it's like also
i think you guys would agree your
writing has shifted completely
like you bring up my wife it's like
there was a good five or six years where
my wife and i we were writing together
regularly
i mean we didn't have five kids or five
kids in three different schools at the
time
so it's like you shift and it's like i
didn't write on stage at that point
and you know like writing on stage doing
longer sets
is really helpful so like during the
pandemic i didn't really write that much
i wish i would have
but
so when i'm doing
longer sets and i also would say that
when i tour
and um
you know during the day i'm not sitting
there going let's meet for coffee i'm
not doing that [ __ ] you know what i mean
yeah i'm kind of like first of all i'm
tired because i've eaten a steak at one
in the morning
but
i'm listening and kind of like that's my
writing time because when i'm home i
don't really have that much time the
road i get a lot down the road hotel
room i love it
i love it i love the road yeah
it's weird people it's just getting
there that's it and getting back
yeah but there's something about the
piece of the road and that you're kind
of like my life's back in new york
that's on hold this is all work yeah and
i bring up like gary veeder usually so i
have a guy just with me who wants to
work on jokes and we can just bounce
bits at lunch we go to our room and i
love the
i love the road yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
about the st louis arch i'm writing i've
seen it yeah i mean there is like
it's good to expose yourself to things
but
it's also
you know there is that that strange
period where you're
wasting time when you're writing that
you have to put in yeah yeah you have to
sit there like it would be embarrassing
to explain how long it took to come up
with attack i know i know i heard gary
goldman once say you build a special one
sentence at a time and it's so true
because you'll be on you'll do a
five-day road stint and you're like i
got that one one line
and then you're happy with it you know
you're like that worked that was
progress it's weird and when there's a
bad audience i always think it's so
weird when or you're just not it's just
not working
and you're and then a line just comes
out and you're like wow yes i never
thought i'd get this line from you
[ __ ] people but it took their
shittiness to bring it out yes yeah
it's weird how about a good crowd can do
the same because they're with you so
hard you're like i'll throw in another
line let's see well i think that's also
a big advantage is the
familiarity an audience has with your
sensibility
you increases the intimacy
so therefore you're it's a safer bet
like i even think like do you remember
when like um
michelle uh wolf got so much [ __ ] for
that white house correspondence thing
like i think that was a classic example
of people didn't know her right right so
like if they knew her i mean they they
couldn't look at it as a comedian like
as a comedian we're like great writing
great performing nailed it yeah but like
to these people they're like who is this
person
yeah that where if it was jeff ross
they'd be like oh it's the roast master
good point jeremy or if it was kathy
griffin they'd be like it's kathy
griffin she's a reverend right because
it broke her
to get your kind of discovery from a lot
of people you're totally right it's it's
the unfamiliarity
so when you do perform
you know in a city that you've been like
whether it be chicago or and you have a
familiarity
they're like yeah let's have some fun
let's see what he's come up with lately
yeah yeah it is weird when people don't
make the connection like i did the joke
earlier about yeah i'm for written house
and people were like you did you're like
what are you [ __ ] not joking but they
don't know you so they don't know right
norm was the king of that he would go to
the espys or he did the correspondent
whatever and the crowd's like what the
[ __ ] is this this guy drunk is he psycho
but the crowd at home is like this is
amazing right because we know him yeah
do you when you were doing the first new
hours you did the half hour but then
you're on the road headlining and i know
you have fans because that half hour was
when comedy center actually like people
would watch it yeah but
you didn't have the fans you have now so
that next hour was that
what made you be like oh i got to flush
all this well the
you know there's also
um you know like there's you either get
too much respect
or none right
there's no in between right you're
either like oh i don't know if i should
be invited to this or you're like no i
can come in and watch i'm a comedian i
can watch another comedian they're like
i don't know who the [ __ ] you are yes
and so um
i would say so after my f
my half hour at comedy central
which i did the same night as geraldo
yeah
and um were you on the same crowd
we are on i think we're on the same page
no no he did he did uh
earlier show i did the later show but
him i wonder if it was the same crowd
i mean obviously you guys met him but
like he had this likability thing yeah
where it was just like you know he got
me into clubs on long island like they'd
be like who's this guy and they're like
he's my friend i'm like i don't know how
to talk to people
and um
but so he'd has he did like four half
hours
because he was in development with
comedy
and i was like i want to do a second one
i want to do a second one they're like
nah that's all right and like what they
told me is that my half hour
was doing well enough oh
talk about broken logic i was told
they're like yeah we don't need it
enough people are watching your old one
we don't need another one i'm like that
doesn't make sense yeah well now we'll
air the office uh for 48 straight hours
this was back when they used to just you
know like comedy central used to
you know like if you had a special on
there
they would air it
four times a day yeah wow four times a
day i remember you talking about those
colleges that was one of them so yeah
like that's where i discovered you it's
really true yeah
you know like people just getting expo
and you're like what yeah and not just
seeing it once seeing it twice right and
so
um but so i was trying to get another
half hour and they were like no thanks
we're all right and there was no other
bets and like
hbo so then i only got the hour because
my manager at the time
was
partners with a guy that had been
in uh ron white's manager who was part
of the blue collar thing so they were
buying these blue collar
you know specials is that murray
mcmurray no alex murray is my manager
mcdonald mcdonald that was it and so he
he essentially got me my special i mean
i got like
no money or anything but it was just to
get
the hour
so
which one was that
beyond the pail oh game changer but but
so like i do think that even
the fact that i had and that's similar
to letterman like i was the last of my
generation to do
a late night show back when they were
really important
and um like i just couldn't get out of
me yeah i was the last in my friend
group i mean everybody's been on it but
me and i remember being like am i
[ __ ] like this is killing me am i
crazy yeah but once you got it you were
ready once i got it i hate first time i
did conan i like i look back i still
like the jokes i hated the crowd it was
tough to wait that long to get on and
then and my second one was to this day
the best late nights that i've ever had
but uh that's the thing about those late
nights is the crowd is everything and i
feel like letterman always was high
letterman it was no better
amazing because there was a gamble
it was a uh because that was a tourist
destination people would get tickets i
went
and would go to new york city because
they got letterman tickets so they were
that was the show they were just like
they just wanted to be at the ed
sullivan theater so it was like the
easiest crowd in the world yeah if
anything you had to stop applause breaks
because there's the
the uh
you know the applause people would be
like i got seven applause rex i'm like i
think we're going for laughs
[Laughter]
yeah but it's funny the juxtaposition of
like
you go from these grimy bar room smoky
rooms are getting heckled and bombing
and then you bring that same killer act
to this
easy peasy you know shoe-in show and you
get to be a star for six minutes it's
weird because it used to be
um the people i mean now it sounds like
i'm making this up but like the people
that would go to comedy clubs were not
the same people that would
go to the letter right right of course
now i think it's become much more um
like stand-up comedies become more
domesticated yeah that sounds like
[ __ ] but it's like
it used to be just kind of
the weirdos like the comedians
it's now it's a middle-class occupation
before it was like
it was degenerates and yeah and misfits
you're in a basement all night yeah yeah
it was weird talking about your dick or
whatever yeah the late night so you
first time you did letterman how did you
get it
i got it
um
because i think i had
got i mean it's like talk about like
no respect and then too much respect so
i auditioned for letterman and conan the
same night and they oh here's how i got
letterman
so
they had this idea
this is back when it was um this you
know like eddie bro wasn't there it was
and they had an idea they wanted to do a
premier week
they would do a comedian every single
night
so it had to be their network premiere
so because i had never been on a late
night show
i had an advantage right so all my
friends who had done i mean like ian
bagg had probably done conan
10 times wow really yeah and you know
geraldo had done all the stuff all these
things
and so because i hadn't done it
they um
that helped me get it and so i remember
that week
who else was on
but
that week i think a lot of the comedians
bombed
so a lot of the comedians
didn't do that well and uh because i
feel like i mean i honestly i mean i was
so ridiculous i like after a year i was
like i should be on letterman
i mean i should definitely be on letter
i'm better than that guy yeah i didn't
say that out loud hopefully we all do
that but uh so it's shocking how long it
takes oh yeah
because you see your progress like no
one else does but you're like i've been
killing i'm doing this many sets a night
i'm killing no one notices but me so you
start to feel like a crazy person tell
them well you are a crazy person yeah
it is it's such an insane pursuit and
you can't explain it to people like what
are you doing and i used to be like
i do this and i get paid when i get paid
i get eight dollars
[Laughter]
what are you talking about the bills are
crumpled up right a guy hands it to me
in a handshake yeah he resents me for
having to be paid
right and the cab ride is 10 to get
there yeah i have to chase someone down
yeah they're annoyed that they have yeah
it's uh
but we have the luxury of doing it now
well not i mean we've been doing it 15
years or whatever but now comics can say
i'm a comic at a dinner party and other
people go cool
but back in your day in the 40s it was
like hey yeah no you know what does that
mean what do you mean you were
definitely someone who was mentally ill
or the question was have you been on
tonight yes exactly if you hadn't been
on the tonight show it was the
equivalent of
uh you know saying that you were not you
had an uh a novel that you wrote but you
didn't have a publisher yeah yeah yeah
insane did your first letterman did they
tinker with the set a lot were they like
you can't say this you can't say that
did that no because that happens with us
a lot but
that
that happened later on
later so once you were already
established they're messing with
yourself isn't that weird yeah they
trust you after a few sets
that was that happened later on and then
i was
yeah no they did trust
well it's like i don't you know like you
don't know what was going on there
but i do know that
you know letterman would be like what
the hell was that guy saying um do you
know what i mean
or if it was
they you know dealing with
uh
you know with the network criticism of
filth right right i mean that was
like letterman and conan doing sets on
there definitely made me
uh again these these were important
shows like that could
you could sell tickets like show people
would
i mean this is before twitter you know
what i mean it's like crazy you would uh
so if you were on letterman
you could sell out a show at the dc
improv wow
you know i mean
not all of them
but people would be like he was on
letter yeah
and um so like
the uh so anyway so getting on conan or
letterman they would be like well you
obviously can't say [ __ ] yeah you
obviously can't say
like you couldn't say crackhead whoa
so
you'd be like all right so
you know again you're like all right and
what i realized is like when there were
curse words in there
it was the joke was just not written
right not done of course yeah and then i
don't know it's so weird it's like this
journey of like
uh
you know there's certain you know
there's some people that should curse
it's
part of their authenticity right good
boy it's like is lewis black not
supposed to curse is chris rock not
supposed to curse it's like of course
they should yeah yeah and you don't see
chris rock on late night yeah not doing
a panel panel yeah yeah totally but it's
different yeah i had to fight to get
boner on the tonight show really and i
fought and it hit and i remember the
roots left and i remember going to the
booker being like you see
you see but boner's a funnier word than
erection
yeah i wasn't trying to be edgy i was
just trying to be funny yeah but i feel
like now the late nights are getting
really curated almost to death oh they
are oh it's worse now and it's weird
because it's like you guys have kind of
lost your power
it's like when i work on a late night
set now i'm like this is time i'm taking
away because i'm still trying to
workshop it and and run it and i'm like
i'm workshopping it for the lowest
ratings you've ever had
and i could be working on my social
media [ __ ] yeah which is doing better
you know way more views i mean there is
something about uh
you know
[Music]
you know it's like kind of like
different i'm sure you guys do this it's
like you'll like i would say this to ted
or todd glass alexandra yeah love ted
and um we'll be like yeah crowd was yeah
and then we'd be like but it's good it's
good to have that
it's good to have that because then it
makes you you know it kind of toughens
you up
for um so like i do think that
or i used to think when i did those tv
sets it was really it was kind of like a
a fine cleaning yes of these jokes i
agree with fine cleaning but that being
said
it's
it's you know it might also put it to
rest a little bit
because once i would do it on letterman
or conan i wouldn't do it on tv again
and so
you would never put those jokes in the
special i would put them in a special i
wouldn't put them on like
and again none of these clips ended up
on youtube it was just like
occasionally on myspace someone would be
like he did the same joke on letterman
you're like what yeah i got that for
america's got talent i'm like yeah i'm
trying to not get heckled by the judges
dude i'm trying to not embarrass myself
in front of 10 million people i'll
repeat a joke i did on you know
whatever of course yeah yeah and that
and those people like todd uh
barry has a great uh attitude on that
it's like those are like
three people out of
five million yeah totally
but we cater to those psychos all the
time well it is like i do think that
like people that are passionate about
comedy
are
the they're the most important people
right i mean except for your peers
they're the ones that like
come out uh that that also
you know you want to you want to have
that influence it's kind of like when
you do like
when when i used to tour and you do like
a road gig and you bring it back to not
even the city but like to brooklyn to
like some
hipster room and they'd be like really
you're doing that joke and you're like
oh [ __ ] sorry i uh
i mean like you get lazy yeah like it's
really
it's really important i haven't done
this in a while but like it's important
to do
different rooms different rooms yeah you
got to mix it up you always have done
that i remember seeing you at cabin all
those bars yeah back in the day and i
respect that i was like oh [ __ ] he's
trying to i mean we've talked about this
before but like you workshop it
everywhere you see where it's not
hitting you're like well maybe i can
strengthen it so it hits here too
but uh i i agree with you on the uh
on the commenters how they're important
but at the same time i do think it's our
nature to like even when you're on stage
you see one person like this in the
crowd and i focus on them saying like it
is also in our blood to just be like
that [ __ ] doesn't like me yeah
okay absolutely and you go that's dad to
me that's just like oh that's my father
pissed and not enjoying it
but there is something about
the um but i do think that like you can
get caught up in
seeking you're never gonna get everyone
i feel like that's true kevin brennan
would obsess on people in the audience
like what lady what are you saying i'm
like dude you were killing killing not
not out loud i'm saying in here yeah
yeah
once you start to obsess over them out
loud you're like well now you're ruining
it for every other person that's happy
to be there you know now and it's
particularly in uh
you know in a comedy club environment
where they're right around you i mean
there's also something about
i mean i'm totally a nerd about this
like where it's
you know there are environments that are
far more interactive
yeah like the conversation
stand-up comedy is a conversation
and if you're on a stage like a gotham
that's a stage but if you're at the
seller you're kind of
you're you know like people at a union
meeting have more authority than you
yeah i mean like your stage is this high
you're barely off the ground and that's
not to say it's bad
it's just a different dynamic so in
other words it's
it's more
um
effective
for people that are doing shorter jokes
and also for people that are you know
like the seller again i haven't been on
that stage in 25 years but like
i would do benefits you would pop in
i've done the underground i don't you
don't you don't like the seller it's not
like no it's not it's not that it's that
you know it's like one of those things
where
you know as you guys know you have to
protect yourself
from like giving your power away yes and
so there came a time where i was sitting
there
and i was like how many spots did i get
at the seller oh i only got that oh i
got this
and i would see my friends
and i would be like all right you know
what i just want to develop material
i want to do it in different places
there is also like the i i knew that
like i i had done so many
so much hanging out i didn't want to do
the hang out i want to do my set and
leave
and this is before i had kids i was like
i want to do my set and leave
and so
there there was a culture there of
hanging out which by the way seems it
seems great i'm not criticizing it at
all do i mean
but like
the whole thing of like giving the power
away i didn't want to do that and like
playing the game
whereas
geraldo was a master at it you know and
that's not to say that people are
kissing ass or anything like that it's
just like
i don't want to play that game i want to
do my stand-up
and then get out of there you're more of
an introvert i don't think it's a power
thing you kind of just want to kind of
you're also i i look at your stuff as
like a lot of people that hang out
aren't always i mean greg was an
incredible writer but not everyone who
does that is
really focused on writing good points
the rare case a lot of people that are
hanging out are kind of like the the
boisterous type where they're kind of
you know they're they're [ __ ] on
people and that's hilarious and that's
great yeah but you're i think i look at
you as a very in-your-head type of like
disciplined it's so weird right now like
geraldo and i
like the fact that he ended up doing
roasts was like one of the biggest
shocks really
he was so great he was a master i think
he was i think he's the best ever at it
and jesse joyce shout out for a lot of
those jokes who is an excellent roast
writer writer but like
it was one of those things where again
it goes back to
you know look obviously roasting is an
art form it's it's obviously uh
if people enjoy it but
if you're if you look at it it's put
down humor sure and now put down humor
look by the way sarcasm has failed
hostility all this [ __ ] you can you can
you can make it really uh nasty but like
i remember i saw seinfeld
at
the comic strip
christmas story a christmas party and
that used to be a big deal oh we used to
go to that free booze free food yeah and
like ray romano would do movies i'm
gonna do a movie and you'd be like ray
romano did a movie
and um seinfeld was like i'm just here
he goes uh you know instead of doing
stuff like this i just work on my act
and it was just like which is perfect
jerry because he is this
um king of cups
yes and so
there is something but like the
practical side of
of roasting is
it it seems a little
uh
waste of time eh maybe or you know not
to
it's like are you bringing light you
know by the way like don rickles
beloved by everyone
uh you know
he he was the master at that too but he
had an act but he was also bringing
light i don't know that's true
i just saw of rickles i believe roasting
shirley mclean she was old as hell in
this clip so was he he must've been in
his 80s and he's roasting everyone in
the room and it's cool to see everyone
like get me yeah yeah yeah
it's rare to see that now now it's
gotten so vicious with the rose that the
part of it's like [ __ ] what are they are
they gonna bring up like yeah it was a
delicate touch i was i did uh bob saget
had this
he bob saget is like
has an amazing relationship with
everybody in the entertainment industry
and he's the nicest person he's the
nicest he's a great guy at
this benefit he had queen latifah
uh you know a lot of range
don don rickles
john mayer
and you're like sitting there and i did
a set and i'm sitting next to it and
then some i don't know like someone who
started
the movie industry you know i mean he's
got goldwood mayor and so don rickles
was orson wells here they walked over
and they gave him a microphone and he
just started making fun of everyone and
it was just like
the best i think i think geraldo was an
incredible roaster i love i i do think
what you're saying is now that with like
the pop you know popularity of things
like roast battle a lot of those comics
are like two years in
right they don't have an act they don't
have a self-deprecating joke about
themselves but they've got five minutes
on some dude they've never met yeah and
they're going up at the comedy store so
that to me that's like but i guess if
it's if it's writing it's it is
productive and it's a way to get in and
for greg it was like the roasts were
huge so that was so interesting
he was you know
you know i have this theory about greg
is that
you know
uh
what you have to understand is that like
and this is my perspective completely is
that
greg toronto was brilliant
uh and i don't say that in a cute way
like he was a really smart guy oh yeah
so he was like
his parents were both immigrants he got
into regis
harvard law harvard law columbia
scholarship all the way worked for like
the biggest law firm in the world
gave it all up
uh you know to pursue stand up he was so
pure at this
and
and what i think
the the amount of failure and
humiliation
he
you know i don't know but like it almost
was like
it took its toll on him harder because
he's like all i do is win
and and that was not his personality his
personality was not like i win right it
was just the track record like he could
go into a club
he was he was engaging he was not a
sycophant he had a confidence and a
rapport whether it was
long island or or the upper east side he
could connect with all these types of
people so like
when and i was there when he got his
sitcom deal
and the you know it's more of like how
the level of cruelty
the entertainment industry is
like he had a manager not a manager an
agent
that
was his agent that you know
plucked him out of uh uh you know
uh montreal
and then within two years
he saw her at a restaurant and she acted
like she didn't know him damn damn
and you're like wow i i got an agent out
of montreal
and uh
he left the company after signing me two
months later and i didn't get an email
didn't that wild
this is an ugly business i mean
greg
you know you talk about how brilliant he
is and you talk about the cruelty of of
this business but like his humility was
you know that always struck me as that
like he could talk to anybody and like i
was like man that guy would have been a
great late-night host
when john john stewart leaves a daily
show who the hell is better than geraldo
well by the way who is an unpretentious
liberal which is kind of like what
liberals need right now oh yeah with all
this woke [ __ ] you need a guy like
greg
who can keep it real who can connect
with both sides of the aisle i mean this
is a guy who would crush in cincinnati
in kentucky in manhattan like that that
is necessary
to
you know as an entertainer but also as a
human
yeah no he actually so his
he had so many pilots at comedy central
that um
you know he had a friday night you're
better off having a pilot on malaysian
airlines at this point but but you know
this was this you know comedy central
had more weight back then oh yeah but
like there was also
so he really popped on tough crowd i
only did tough crowd twice but like he
really popped and he by the way that's
that was like one of those things where
you know like that combined with the
roast because the format of tough crowd
was very much
a roasting environment yeah
it was guys being guys kind of thing
ball busty yeah
and
so there was
they canceled
um a tough crowd
then comedy central
begged
greg to redo tough crowd
without colin
disgusting he asked colin colin goes
fine
he got [ __ ] for it
they
so there was that that didn't work there
was also a talk show
that i wonder if i did a guest set on it
but also like how [ __ ] up is that like
but like
greg's clearly looked up to colin we all
look up to colin you know yeah and uh i
don't care for her
but greg clearly look up to him he's a
guest on the show colin yeah and then
you're like step in and do the show he's
like that's well that's just that's just
the stupidity of the business and this
is also like he's probably got two kids
he's you know
uh
they're like do this and we've done six
six deals with you six pilots
but there was a time
when
he they were gonna do another show he
was to be the host of it
and they tested and i'm like this is it
greg's on his way
and um
that was when the daily show
was really peaking
and they were like they're just gonna
and there was also a time when there was
a power base in comedy central in la and
a power base in new york
and greg was associated with the la
group but the power base in new york was
the daily show
and i think chappelle and so
so the power base in la had less
influence i think
and so they gave that time slot which is
by the way comedy central has so many
time slots they gave it to stephen
colbert
so it's like that close right
and that was a great show and that was a
hit a great show so yeah you're right
it's it's tough but it's so painful that
you're like you put in the work like
greg did you're right there and and
there is
a cruelty in this business that like you
do have to keep getting up from yeah i
mean by the way chappelle was who was
also a
phenom of phenom and like would uh
destroy on a on a kind of otherworld
level
had sitcom after sitcom after sitcom uh
that would fail
so it was
it was very a weird thing and i remember
like
you know geraldo he was like i want a
tour doing uh headlining and i'm like i
don't want to do that
i just wanted to be a writer on
letterman really so it's like when did
that change for you
i think
i had done uh
welcome to new york and then i that
experience was so horrible like that's
what's weird also about stand up is you
you know you go on stage you're
essentially writer director producer
and then you get in these group settings
yep and you're like people like that's
good enough you're like but it's it's
not yeah and they're like don't be
difficult right and so i was like all
right i'm just gonna do stand-up and try
and get acting jobs and i never got any
acting jobs you're in a lot of you're
the hemi guy
i was not the heavy guy yeah that was uh
damn it well you know commercials that
was the other white fat guy
did that 70s show help you on the road
when you're on that yes
that's a good show i was very lucky
because there was
before uh when i was touring before
beyond the pale i had that 70s show
i had a sex in the city thing and i also
had right wow that was a big show
what was the uh
i can't remember you own another ship my
boys too
my boys that was kind of after the thing
gotcha but but that 70s show was huge
yeah that 70s show was
like
i don't know if you've been to a
four-camera shoot it's one of the most
boring things in the world but people
would come and hang out
like young hollywood we were just
talking about kurtwood smith and deborah
joe rupp and saying how great they both
are oh yeah so good it's like insane how
good they both are they're so funny yeah
and sh by the way it's like
did you see her on wandavision like
she's still going oh yeah no i didn't
she's in everything she was on seinfeld
back i mean she's a great character
actor yeah
and he was also
he was in robocop yeah was he also in um
uh beverly hills comp was that him i'm
not sure maybe he's i don't think he was
the first one i don't know he was but
he's better than his cop every watch
recently by the way it's still so damn
good it's such it's such a good movie oh
yeah eddie murphy a lot of talent
like it's insane how talented he is it's
like there's the fame thing yeah and
there's like selling tickets but like as
uh an actor
like it is insane like i i don't get
like the the
the clumps no matter what you think of
it
go when he pulls off in that you're like
holy [ __ ] i've i've said on this podcast
i think he should have been nominated
for an oscar for nutty professor i've i
totally agree with him yeah i think it's
incredible i i love eddie murphy i mean
coming to america isn't to me the most
impressive performance is not a
professor just because like
he's playing so many like full
characters it's incredible well he's
also like the level of
uh empathy
that he
creates yeah
you know because you know he's this guy
with an ego and he's in here we are
talking about
but he embodies this
this guy that's
likable
miserable fat guy you're like oh right
right yeah yeah i was just watching have
you seen that show on netflix the movies
that made us and there's one coming to
america and they go into how eddie
murphy couldn't get any air time on snl
and these two writers were like i like
this guy's good we should write for him
more and they were trying to use him to
get bigger and he was using them to get
bigger and then they end up writing
coming to america together wow but it's
incredible that i think the through line
of this whole episode is the industry is
clueless
the industry stinks
we gotta come in and write jokes and do
whatever but but there's never been a
better time you know for yes because you
know sure it's diluted but
you can put [ __ ] on tick tock and
youtube and and facebook and instagram
and anything so like thank god you can
do all those things after you watch my
special dude comedy monster on netflix
just came out norma's got a new special
too you should watch both of them i mean
we're working sam's not doing anything
i'm taking a break i just went to a
beach
in upstate new york you're engaged you
got engaged congratulations
he got engaged to the christian and
you're gonna become a christian now i'm
gonna be a christian finally talking
about uh
we don't do a lot more jesus talking
this pod i think that's what's been
missing here yeah you go chris i'll go
jew we'll mix it up you just want to be
a jew really badly everyone every
comedian does
i'm i love that comedians like us
yes that's nice that's about it
but yeah well actually the christians uh
in america are obsessed with israel so
that's true good point the far right
loves israel man they're like that's
their yeah they really do
i heard you guys got bombed recently
in israel you see that that was on this
podcast
let me out before we gotta go i yeah
just to skew off comedy yeah you got 17
kids yes i'm thinking about having a kid
yeah what what this is this is a bomb
drop on the podcast we're getting older
and who better to ask than the uh the
father of nine here what do you think
any uh is it horrible is it terrifying
do you hate them do you want to kill
them do you like abortion talk
you know i think i think i recommend it
really i mean it's really hard by the
way i've got five of them and uh in
manhattan in manhattan you're the most
prolific comic and you have uh more kids
and specials somehow
no i don't know about that no you're
more special but close the but it's it's
yeah i mean it's taxing i mean i hang
out with myself i mean life is filled
with misery you might
join this is a tough sales pitch for
kids right here does the joy outweigh
the misery yeah
yes okay well i also believe
that like people need to do things to
evolve uh-huh and i think that
you know
i'm jordan peterson i think you have to
become a monster
you have to i wish i could do his accent
me too so high
yeah
but yeah no i think it's a strange thing
because it's like it does make you a
better person okay but
and i think how about your selfishness
does it help your comedy
i think so i i think also it's uh it's a
very abundant universe so like there's
also the fear factor yes you're like oh
gotta make sure that
this person's taken care of
but um yeah i don't know i mean look i
just did
uh you know i was just on vacation with
my family and we did disney world which
i never want to do again but i keep
doing it every two years
dude you're by the way if you haven't
seen jim's disney world chunk in mr
universe oh you gotta cue that up too on
netflix because that's another that's
one of my favorite specials ever i mean
and um you can write all that up but now
i feel like
um you know that's if you want to feel
like you were the symptoms of covet just
go to you know walk around disney world
for 10 hours
so but i do think that that's a sad
sight what else are you gonna do with
your life
true i mean it's you can just live it
happily and fun well you don't have to
get a pet either you know i mean right
you don't have to travel to another
country
you know i mean it's
you don't have to create more material
you know what i mean good point so
that's a good point i don't know it's
got to be the right person
you know
to have the kid with uh like i think
people with
disney or goofy and uh that's a tweet
comedians are children so is the person
that you're gonna have the kid with are
they
are they a non-child no i mean she's
wheelchair bound but other than that
she's not going anywhere
i got a broomstick in the wheel
but yeah yeah all right all right
i like that i like that but
i hang with my nieces and nephews and
the whole
it's beautiful and it's great but you
get to leave
with the kid you don't leave with is the
road really hard with kids or is it
great great tom papa joke oh yeah you
know he goes well you got five kids oh
why how do you how do you go on the road
it must be a miserable he's like yeah
the hardest part is trying not to
whistle while i pack come on
that's a brilliant joke
yeah i mean there is i mean look there
is something of uh why
you know not to sound like a piggish guy
that's why guy play guys play golf right
they
it's they don't like golf they don't
want to get out of the house totally
that's exciting joke get out leave
family you know it's the goal so the um
you're drinking while playing a sport
outside yeah and so the uh it is a sport
but you know what i mean right right you
know it's
it's pretty uh it's pretty amazing okay
and there's not a single kid that i
would trade in
but it is i mean look it's scary it's
like you're like
you hope that the kid's okay
the you know you the news the local news
becomes really more important oh wow i
mean it's like this nomadic life that we
lead
you know it's not like you know putting
a down payment on an apartment it's like
you're in you're in yeah yeah you can't
flip it in the next two years you can't
flip it and you can't sit there and
tear it all down but it's it's part of
uh growing up i think
i don't know well seinfeld is like you
know the famous thing of like i don't
want to be have kids i don't ever want
to get married and now he's like if i
didn't have kids i'd be miserable blah
blah wow so
bill burr same thing i actually heard
jordan peterson say the same thing
really weirdly yeah i don't say like
that's like his meaning for like you
know getting older it's like his meaning
for life so and it kicks you into gear i
know like chris d
had a kid he was like i gotta work i
gotta get out there i gotta write more
and you know louie said the same thing
two kids it makes you
happy and there's some comics who are
like i had a kid i'm moving upstate new
york that's true i do a road gig every
two months and you're like all right
well you're out so yeah so there's that
fear too yeah but i think that i think
you have to
that's where you have to be with the
right person that gets
who you are you know i mean
and that we are children yeah
yeah we really are
i've
[ __ ] myself
um
all right well [ __ ]
this is the best episode of the show
ever i think it is man
thank you guys for this classic thanks
for listening to the geraldo podcast
watch watch jim gaffigan comedy monster
he's got a bunch of other specials on
netflix uh you know seriously one of our
favorites you know so appreciate you
coming on he takes that every week
coming up next wilson vince one of my
favorites oh my gosh she's the best
really
any any parting words any notes of
advice any life
hack you got anything
comedy better now or then
when you start your audience is better
educated with about stand-up more savvy
for sure
um
but you know i mean
i've been hearing a lot more let's go
brandon's in the audience so i don't
know i think it's the wittiest thing
you're like
you're you're doing i'm rick james [ __ ]
but it's but
it's the same it's like
it's the that's crazy create your own
[ __ ] joke
you know yeah yeah
but all right we did it i got to go
well
uh
gigs you want to do oh yeah you got some
dates richmond baltimore hartford
sacramento beacon theater new york
please come out oh wow that's in may 9th
wow i think it's may 7th actually but i
appreciate it yeah pretty good toronto
over oh yeah it's
it's almost full so please keep moving
it and milestone yeah and toronto all
that [ __ ] uh columbus miami palm
beach back to miami
oh not miami uh [ __ ] orlando uh thanks
for catching that same [ __ ] uh
samurail.com shows
all right i'm at a sacramento la jolla i
love how you guys have this memorized
i'm trying uh kansas city syracuse
uh chicago
some other stuff mark normancomedy.com
check us out check out old episodes
are you in chicago when i'm in chicago
either in april march oh really you can
you can tell everyone do when you do
press
mention my shows you got it in april
just follow jim on every social follow
him on instagram on on every tick tock
everything twitter and uh you know see
him on tour yes the hemi guy one last
time
[Laughter]
thank you so much
thank you
[Music]
so
[Music]
you